following up on yesterday's story that
former Trump aide and Breitbart
propaganda Stephen Bannon is being
indicted again again for his build the
wall scam it has happened yesterday
Stephen Bannon did indeed surrender to
the Manhattan District Attorney's office
he made quite a scene here is Bannon
showing up and he starts screaming and
then someone in the crowd is screaming
and it's just a complete and total mess
[Music]
on the very day the mayor of this city
has a delegation Down On the Border
they're persecuting people here
so Bannon yelling about the Border a
bystander yelling stop hurting America
what a mess
take a step back
[Applause]
greasy grifter I like I have to tell you
that I like
a bit I agree with as well now if you
don't remember what this is all about
Steve Bannon and a guy named Brian
colfage were raising money to build
their own wall on the U.S Mexico border
a complete and total absurdity an
obvious scam and indeed it was here's
just 20 seconds because this is all I
can take from when they did this
wallathon
Stephen K bennan and Brian colfage
welcome back this is Stephen K Bannon
we're off the coast of San Tropez in
southern France in the Mediterranean
we're on the million dollar yacht yeah
Brian colfage and Brian Colfax he took
all that money from build the wall no
we're actually in Sunland Park New
Mexico
well it turns out that they really did
abscond with the money uh Brian colfage
did and uh it's it's beyond parody that
this is now where we are Steve Bannon
was
um pardoned by Donald Trump on the
federal charges for this build the wall
scam that pardon presidential pardons
don't apply to State charges these are
now State charges in the state of New
York and here it goes all over again uh
one other just really funny note adding
stupidity to absurdity Steve Bannon went
surrendering yesterday did yell out
Trump won I mean these people are are
parodies of themselves
Trump won bidens a legitimate this
oh God these people are pathetic so
we'll follow the trial and there is no
presidential pardon coming this time and
that will be very interesting to see
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and Bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa Honey Nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
Maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
I love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but but I know it's about to
become your new favorite cereal you'll
get five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com Pacman the link is down
below